[Musica]
ciao è arrivata una giovane finalmente
ragazzi tranquilli
allora io penso che tutti nella vita
abbiamo la possibilità di vivere di
provare delle esperienze che in qualche
modo ci trasformano in qualche modo ci
cambiano
ecco nella mia vita c'è stata
un'esperienza in particolare che forse
ha segnato più delle altre mio percorso
è stata una meningite batterica che ho
avuto nel 2011 che kemal cambiato a
livello esteriore credo
evidentemente sono trasformata mi trovo
diversa però non credo di essere
cambiata poi così tanto in fondo nel
profondo
sicuramente è stato un evento che ha
stravolto la mia vita di quel delle
persone che mi stavano attorno e è stato
come essere catapultati in un grande
caos per per un bel po per per circa un
anno di ray e sicuramente non è stato
facile come potrete immaginare
mi sono chiesta tantissime volte perché
fosse capitato proprio a meno di tutte
le persone brutte che ci sono al mondo
proprio a me o mi chiedevo mentre un
ospedale cosa avrei fatto poi della mia
vita cosa avrei potuto fare una risposta
questa queste domande non c'era e non
c'è una spiegazione però forse proprio
in questi momenti difficili uno deve
fare un po una scelta e c'è la
possibilità di scegliere
di essere un po sopraffatti dalle
difficoltà da un evento così duro e
penso che se anche l'esito è
giustificabile fare questa scelta però
c'è anche un'altra scelta quella per cui
forse ci vuole un po più di coraggio ma
che regala tante occasioni che è quella
di di rendersi un po conto prendere atto
della realtà di guardarsi un attimo lo
specchio e guardare quello che è rimasto
non quello che non c'è non quello che
avrebbe potuto esserci ma di riprendere
un po in mano le redini della situazione
e cercare di andare avanti anche in modo
molto positivo e questo questo evento
così traumatico nos pensa sempre che
debba cambiare tutto di te un evento
così difficile per chi di voi nella vita
no ha subito un trauma pensa che sia la
sua vita sia stravolta a quel momento
però io credo che nel mio caso mi abbia
fatto veramente capire quali quali erano
quali siano le mie abilità e non ridete
lo so che sono diventata la persona
disabile però ho scoperto dell'abilità
nuove e e proprio per fare per farvi
capire meglio no quello che intendo
praticamente un esempio l'altro giorno
ho incontrato un mio amico un ragazzo in
stazione a roma io non lo vedevo da otto
anni
l'ho conosciuto in vacanza studio l'anno
prima di ammalarmi nel 2010 e sapete
quelle persone che magari veramente
incontrato una volta la vita ma ti
rimangono un po nella memoria che hanno
lasciato quel calore che quando l'ho
incontrato ovviamente ero felicissima e
mi ha sorpreso mi ha preso un po in
contropiede perché mi ha detto sai
veroniche io ti ho seguito un po dei so
se ho seguito la tua storia
io non mi aspettavo niente di meno da te
da quella ragazza che ho conosciuto otto
anni fa perché eri già curiosa già piena
idea è così e ovviamente questa cosa mi
ha fatto insomma un super onore e ero
felicissima però come proprio
se mi avesse dimostrato nella forza
formidabile che ha la capacità di essere
integri di rimanere se stessi nonostante
tutto è come se li avesse fatto un po
vedere due foto di una prima è una dopo
in tutte in entrambe mi conosco in
entrambe sono io come qua dietro sono la
veronica che sogna grandi occasioni solo
che sono in un corpo un pochettino
diverso sono sono cresciuta in qualche
modo sono cresciuta e ho la possibilità
di raccontarmi spesso molte persone
quindi secondo me questa malattia è
stata una sorta di acceleratore una
scintilla una una motivazione a dare
tutta me stessa in tutte le occasioni ed
è fantastico perché è come se ognuno di
noi avesse il proprio percorso già già
un po scritto e dovessero trovare
appunto un'idea una parola un'emozione
una scintilla chiamatela come volete che
spinga a veramente metterci tutta la
passione che che può esserci per me è
stato un momento particolare il momento
in cui mi europa e altri 28 runner suoi
amici hanno deciso di una volta uscita
dall'ospedale di portarmi a new york
ma facciamo un passo indietro quando era
in hospice stata cinque mesi in ospedale
no e deve imparare ad affrontare certe
cose che a 15 anni
magari non sei pronta non sei capace ad
affrontare e io non ero assolutamente
capace a chiedere non sapevo chiedere
neanche mia mamma mi preparava al pranzo
non sapevo a chiedere niente infatti era
una di quelle bambine che aveva già non
aveva bisogno di far vedere i diari o ai
propri genitori una che si arrangiava un
abbastanza indipendente e
in ospedale ti trovi a essere dipendente
da tutti a dover chiedere tutto a dover
ti fidare delle persone che guarda ti
devo tagliare un pezzetto però ti salvi
fidiamoci in realtà questa abilità mi
son servite tantissimo quando sono
uscita dall'ospedale
ho intrapreso nella mia carriera
sportiva
e questo quest'abilità del chiedere mi è
tornata utile mi è tornata utile ad
esempio quando quando devo andare dalle
aziende a chiedere di aiutarmi al mio
percorso sportivo devo fa un po la
sfacciata devo chiedere quindi è
importante ma sapete un po che in
università a tutti sono un po tirchi con
gli appunti ecco imparare a chiedere
importante di imparare a chiedere un
modo giusto alle persone giuste e stato
veramente un'abilità che che mi torna
utile sempre è appunto devi fidarti dei
medici che ti dicono che si salveranno
in un certo modo e di infilarli anche di
tuo panne quando torni a casa
dall'ospedale ti dice che ha lo sporty
farà benissimo
tu sinceramente lo sport unci mezza
voglia perché vorresti sta sul divano a
riprenderti da tutto il caos da tutto
quello che ti è successo appunto miapa
con con questi runner decidono di
portarmi alla maratona di new york
io ero ancora in carrozzina quando sono
uscita appunto in quel periodo dall
ospedale il giorno prima della maratona
c'è una 5 km di avvicinamento alla
maratona e decidono insieme di correre
con me per me facciamo questa 5 km
mentre loro mi spingono in carrozzina e
poi facciamo tagliamo il traguardo tutti
insieme camminando ed erano i miei primi
passi no quando da quando sono tornata a
casa
e stata un'emozione incredibile
veramente tale data
grazie ed è proprio come se mi avessero
voluto metter su un trampolino gigante
ne avesse detto veronica guarda questo è
il mare di emozioni che ti può regalare
lo sport lo sai benissimo perché
comunque è lino sportiva non a livello
agonistico di adesso quindi è tua la
scelta io quando sono tornata a casa e
ho deciso che dovevo fare qualcosa
dovevo mettermi in gioco in prima
persona
io vito palazzolo sull'oglio una città
di confine tra brescia bergamo e c'è un
film bellissimo che attraverso e quindi
avevo visto già mio fratello andare in
canoa così ho deciso di scendere al
fiume dove c'è questo club di canoa
bellissimo sono sceso al fiume e
l'approccio è stato fantastico perché il
presidente allenatore e non sapevo come
mi avrebbe trattato era la mia prima
esperienza da atleta paralimpica o come
come si possa dire mia io sono arrivata
in carrozzina con tutte le difficoltà
del genere lui mi ha messo lì la canon e
lacco mi ha detto tieni vai aiuto fatto
dove c è infatti tutti i canoisti che
c'era libera allenarsi mi guardavano il
tifo ma questo dove la vuole andare
queste manine che non riesce neanche a
tenere la pagaia
però piano piano io mi sono messa lì e
da qualche parte sono andata è stato
veramente un approccio che penso che mi
abbia fatto scattare qualcosa lui mi ha
detto guarda noi ci alleniamo il martedì
mercoledì giovedì sabato domenica se
vuoi venire qua se un po allenarci e non
mi sono sentita diversa noi questo è
stato molto importante perché era
all'inizio del mio percorso no questo
trattamento è stato veramente importante
parallelamente iniziato anche or
iniziato a fare snowboard
ho avuto la fortuna di farlo molto
meglio di prima nonostante le difficoltà
fisiche
io ho avuto anche la fortuna di riuscire
andare subito la paralimpiade mio parere
in piedi un evento spettacolare
nello snowboard stata molto fortunata
perché ho iniziato da poco però lo sono
per lo avrebbe fatto il suo debutto come
disciplina paralimpica soci 2014
e c'erano un po di posti c era un po che
ragazze e comunque ci sono andata ed è
stata un'esperienza fantastica
e poi quando sono tornata mi sono messa
di nuovo in canoa
ho iniziato a fare i campionati italiani
e li ho vinti e ho vinto gli europei ha
vinto la coppa del mondo stato un
susseguirsi di cose bellissime
grazie però anche la cosa bellissima
sono tutti gli incontri no che ho fatto
sul percorso tipo a rio 2016 quando sono
andata per la canoa alle mie seconde
paraolimpiadi
ho avuto la possibilità di conoscere la
squadra di paratriathlon e dovrà infatti
faccio triathlon ho avuto la possibilità
di conoscere storie da tutto il mondo
persone che mi hanno veramente
arricchito insomma tutte queste emozioni
occasioni anno mi hanno reso una persona
credo un po migliore e forse non lo
avrei avute senza la meningite
ovviamente se fossi davanti a un bivio
non potrei scegliere di nuovo la
meningite
però questo percorso mi ha regalato
tanto quindi sarebbe anche una scelta
difficile cioè provate a immaginarvi di
a 18 anni
siete appena stati convocati alle
paralimpiadi di entrare in uno stadio in
russia a soci 2014
alla cerimonia di apertura delle
paralimpiadi con 40mila persone che vi
avvolgono voi con la divisa nazionale è
veramente un'emozione indescrivibile
se fosse facile dirlo e descriverlo non
sarebbe così importante andarci
immaginate emozione di portare la divisa
della nazionale rappresentare qualcosa
siete una formica lento questo stadio ma
in realtà rappresentate qualcosa di
importante è un onore incredibile
veramente e tutto questo è
è un valore aggiunto alla mia esperienza
di vita per fortuna sono le uniche
emozioni che che mi ha dato e le uniche
gli unici fattori di crescita che mi ha
dato lo sport in questo in questo
percorso perché lo sport è fatto un po
dalla fatica di tutti i giorni no va
bene la gara va bene la vittoria la
sconfitta però un evento non può
definirsi perché in qualche modo tu sei
un atleta non per la gara che vinci ma
se un atleta perché a tutti i giorni ci
mette impegno e costanza
come quando ho studiate tutti i giorni
no per gli esami che avete a scuola il
verifiche è veramente questo sport come
la canocchia temprata e mia mi ha reso
l'atleta della persona che sono faccio
un esempio del fatto che un evento
veramente non può definirsi quest'anno
sono andata al mondiale in australia di
triathlon la disciplina che ormai sto
facendo da due anni da quando sono
tornata dalle paralimpiadi di rio perché
non mi piace sempre fare le stesse cose
sono una persona un po curiosa è suonata
al mondiale mi sono preparata molto per
questo mondiale tutto l'anno con questo
obiettivo visto nella tantissimo sempre
con in mente questa gara la gara più
importante dell'anno in australia poi
sarebbe stata comunque un'esperienza
importante per me non ero mai stata in
australia
fatto sta che arriva in australia e mi
ammalo l'influenza più brutta della mia
vita avevo fatto un periodo in altura
avevo fatto proprio una popolazione
intense le aspettative erano alte se da
parte mia che da parte delle persone che
mi seguono nel mio percorso sportivo
però per qualche motivo cioè la sfiga di
non riuscire a stare bene quando vuoi
star bene no è come quando immagino
tutti di voi no preparate qualcosa per
cui sono vi siete impegnati tanto un
certo punto c'è qualcosa che non va e
tutta la fatica siamo un po sprecata per
realtà no bisogna vedere proprio il
percorso perché io per arrivare questo
mondiale mi sono allenata tantissimo e
quel valore lidi quell'allenamento
quotidiano mi resta ok la gara non è
andata come volevo però ho fatto
un'esperienza comunque bellissimo ho
fatto una preparazione intensa che vi
serviranno prossimo è meglio perché
magari le mie rivali
spesso chi sono scarsa perché al
mondiale non sono andato bene e l'anno
prossimo arrivo e tac vinco magari in
questo percorso
capite che le occasioni e le opportunità
se state tante le emozioni tantissime
però ultimamente c'è c'è qualcosa che
kimi che sento necessario fare e dire
sapete per me non è mai stato un
problema
il mio corpo perché io faccio questo
lavoro quotidiano sempre con il mio
corpo e quando vedi il tuo corpo che fa
cose straordinarie tutti i giorni si
migliora cresce supereroe pieri miti
tutti i giorni come fa e non adorarlo
quindi le mie cicatrici le mie forme
strane che magari possono non piacere o
fare un po impressione all'inizio non
sono mai stato un problema per me e
ultimamente sto facendo dei progetti per
sensibilizzare condividere questa cosa
con molti ragazzi e ragazze che si
sentono piene di difetti e scommetto che
tutti voi qua vi sentite con qualche
difetto è è una cosa così stupida mi
hanno chiamata per fare delle foto in
costume e io ho detto oddio io in delle
foto in costume siti sicuri però mi
hanno detto appunto che il fine di
questo progetto era dimostrare che la
diversità è bella che la diversità e
bellezza e quindi ci tenevo molto perché
è una cosa a cui tengono per passare a
voi ragazzi anche gli adulti in realtà
ne hanno bisogno
quindi ho detto di sì però non sapevo
quale sarebbe stato il feedback no come
avrebbero reagito le persone il re stato
meraviglioso perché quando sono uscite
queste foto tantissime ragazze e ragazzi
hanno condiviso la propria storia le
proprie insicurezze con me e non mi
aspettavo io di avere questa possibilità
nella vita no questa questa possibilità
di lasciare un segno positivo nella vita
degli altri
d
a motivare qualcuno piacersi ad
accettarsi per quello che si è fatto
veramente qualcosa
un altro regalo grandissimo che mi ha
dato questa strada quindi dopo tutti
questi regali
io ho deciso di ridare qualcosa no le
persone che mi stanno dando tanto nel
2016 quando sono tornata a dar io ho
deciso che il mio club magico il mio
club di di canoa aveva bisogno di un
contributo da me oltre che a quello
fisico di esser lì e rimotivare tutti i
ragazzi e quindi ho deciso di fare una
raccolta fondi per renderlo accessibile
quindi privo di barriere architettoniche
e soprattutto un centro molto più
funzionale di quello che ora ed è
bellissimo vederlo crescere ormai lavori
sono quasi finiti ed è come se alla fine
fosse di fatto un regalo io perché è
veramente bello vedere i ragazzi e le
ragazze che che iniziano il loro
percorso ii che lo continuano è che sono
facilitati da questa struttura che che
dà l'accesso a tutti poi cerco di
motivare un pochettino le persone per un
pizzico di entusiasmo in più nella vita
che spesso manca
ultimamente quindi racconto la mia
storia quando posto a molte persone
quindi oggi sono qua per chiedervi un
altro grande regalo
vi prego di mettere tutti voi stessi
sempre in ogni cosa che fate
grazie
appello
[Musica]